[Music]
welcome back to the sixth annual
Halloween special I'm sitting here with
father Brando one of my best friends
Matt Brando we've done a lot of videos
together I have a whole playlist on my
YouTube channel check it out check out
his channel tons of great content there
are a handful of movies that I said to
you if I ever reviewed them I couldn't
do it without you
it was heat and The Exorcist yeah my two
favorites and we're gonna get into
spoilers so if you've never seen The
Exorcist
obviously we're both recommending the
film you know it's a horror classic for
a reason go see it but we're gonna get
into full spoilers for both a theatrical
and the director's cut I was never
allowed to watch this when I was a kid
it was one of those forbidden movies it
was like I go to Blockbuster I'd see the
VHS of this right there oh it's just for
this review it was that an anime called
ninja scroll it was like for adults only
oh wow it was just one of those
forbidden things where I would pass it
in the store and I'd be like I can't
like I can't even look at that like
that's evil and it was you after I
started hanging out with you more that
was like dude you need to sit down and
really like analyze the Exorcist and
watch it the first time I watched the
film I was a theatrical but we're going
to talk about the director's cut I'm
actually the same way like quick story
for the viewers my upbringing was so
religious that we had Titanic on OPM
here I do we attack on VHS dude react my
parents actually would skip past that
nude paintings of course yeah so I'll
just said this right here and yeah I
took me it's like like early 20s I
probably like manned up and I saw it
hilarious story for an hour on DVD now
blow right during the day not at night
and hooded Cleveland with my friend on
this 19 inch TV not like a 55 inch 4k
thing you know huh and actually it was
like you know you do this thing when you
watch horror films if you're genuinely
scared of it you kind of laugh at it
just a emotional response or trigger to
like not be scared so we kind of just
roasted the film it was like oh look at
this guy he doesn't Jason more father
Karras they could they got him physical
afford Al Pacino and I was like that's
actually
funny but I think that was actually a
thing I think they actually we're about
to cast out but yeah they were I read
that they were interested in Al Pacino
for that role there's a lot Mazda's dad
written to I think Stacy Keach Paul
Newman
I think Brando but like a lot of
big-time names but actually was given to
Jason Miller because freaking saw that
championship season which won the Tony
the Pulitzer and there's something that
the Drama Critics Choice were stuck
there was like known as like the the
Kentucky Derby whatever of film or clip
I'll play criticism and Jason Miller
played father Karras was actually
Catholic and I guess that championship
season it's available on DVD I think you
can watch it they made a movie
production of the play but I guess it
reeks Catholicism and stuff and freakin
sod was like that's my father cares like
that's actually a really cool choice
because it adds more realism into the
film which yes a lot of some personal
depth oh yeah
I think Jason Miller as father Karras is
the emotional backbone of this movie the
notion going in is that it's a demon
movie with it oh yeah yeah green eyes
and she vomits but it's really like so
much deeper than that and a lot of it
has to do with father Karras and his
character and his crisis of faith and
like the exploration of what he's going
through with his mom which makes the
exorcism sequence in the third act so
much more powerful because it's not
really just about you know the power of
Christ compels you and all the the you
know amazing makeup it's it's really a
much more intimate story yeah I think
that's why maybe I can speak for myself
at least took me a while to see it and
then I find I saw it I thought I had
this little revelation I was like wow
that's actually that's me what 15
percent of the movie although glorifying
guts and shit but I actually had this
guy you like comment on my Exorcist read
be like why are you glorifying hell I'm
like that's the dumbest thing I've heard
in my life like you have the Exorcist
the director freaking who was I think
Jewish and I was agnostic but it's kind
of interesting he always says like god
bless the people so and Vladdy as a
Catholic and both of us said like on
video
like how can you say that the devil ones
like that's what freaking set and then
bladdy is like I always said you know
that it's not how it is like it's you
know even at the end
caris lives through quote unquote the
new relationship with kinderman and ire
and i always saw it as a film of faith
and i don't know how anyone could look
at and be like oh the devil's in the
film's cells and like oh my gosh i
completely agree with you it's a movie
about redemption about finding yourself
about accepting your flaws and learning
to live with your flaws but still
pushing through and I've always found
the ending of it
strangely heartwarming and there's a
part in the ending to where the little
girl she she rushes the one priest and
gives him a kiss on the cheek and
watching the film again tonight there's
that moment we're like oh god like where
she about oh okay it's just a nice
little oh yeah yeah yeah yeah like cuz
cuz you get an insert of his priest
collar yeah yeah she sees it and this is
right after the mom says that she
doesn't remember anything that happened
so like to me is that suggesting that
part of her is somehow thankful for
whatever occurred that got this this
thing out of her and that she does kind
of recall some of those events right it
plays into an interesting aspect of this
tug of war that frickin place with the
film I think you're right and she oh she
doesn't remember I think Chris MacNeil
says that but yeah maybe she secretly
does and I don't know almost specifics
but I assume that maybe if it happened
that you remember in real life but just
for dramatics sake I think she she did
remember that's why they had that
close-up but that's a very interesting
like oh my god she could only kill oh my
god for like you know the first time I
saw it yeah why a back I was like oh
shit okay ah because the film keeps you
on edge I mean from the beginning
there's something so subliminal and
there's actual subliminal imagery
especially in the director's cut there's
a lot of those faces but there's
something very subliminal about the way
the film is cut together because
sequences that have nothing horrific
happening there's this cold feeling
that's in developed throughout the whole
film like father Karras jogging and the
detective Lee Jay Cobb is just sitting
on a bleacher and then they have a
conversation
and you know there's no demons in the
scene there's no music in the scene
there's no special effects it's just two
dudes talking and there's something so
off-putting about it unnerving about it
because that shit we've known as you
know the demon shit is in the background
and you know it's there and it's gonna
come as we progress in time and that's
just wonderful craft by frickin by
establishing what I want to say is like
the greatest mood you know me zone scene
and yeah from start to finish like when
I saw it for the first time and I saw
him jump out of this window Karason and
roll down the steps and we see mother
and she's like against the wall I crying
I'm like I can finally breathe now like
I'm never felt that type of tension
release ever seeing a film it's almost
like um almost like an avatar but like
you still watch avatar in the theater in
3d for the first time rather than like
oh I'm seeing at home that well it's not
great but yeah it's just every time you
watch you get that experience and you
have this like unworldly thing you're
watching it's like not even a movie
anymore being transcended into a new
world and it's freaking Oh mind-blowing
The Exorcist is one of those few horror
films that as I watch it it does have
this sense of realism to it that creates
like you said an atmosphere that's just
far beyond what other horror directors
or people who've tried to made make
horror films have been able to achieve I
don't really think freaking has ever
been better than this film I like French
Connection
I even like bug with Ashley Judd and
Michael Shannon but I I think that he
just kind of was tapped into something
else when he was making this movie and I
don't know what that was but there's a
power crisis it compelled him to make a
movie um one of the things I love about
this film is that every film that has
you know been inspired by it look at
movies like the conjuring know I am they
they have a way of telling the story
that's very modern and and it gets
audiences excited I like the conjuring
but it's funny whenever you go back to
the movie that kind of inspired it that
started at all you can see just how
different it is from all of the eventual
products that came afterwards like the
way the film opens in Iraq and in Max
von Sydow father Merrin mm-hmm he's at
this excavation and he finds this little
little artifact and we have no idea what
this artifact is we don't know where
it's from we don't know why it's
bothering him but just the sequence with
him sitting in that room and then the
clock stops yeah and he turns and you
get this shot of him looking almost into
the lens it just fucking stops your
heart and there's no there's no there's
no demon stuff yeah and then there's no
horror stuff yet he's just got this
little prop and you're like why is this
so unnerving already yeah
in the 70s when a film was at least you
know they have this big wave of fear
that happened but now many years later
oh my gosh the scariest movie ever made
and then you watch it like even though
frickin opening credits the directors
cuts in black and white and the
originals not but from the from the
get-go when you watch the director's cut
opens in DC like oh my gosh is this are
you gonna start now just check already
possessed and it doesn't cost Iraq and
playing into the realism this film like
when you see Iraq northern Iraq that
shot in Iraq that wasn't shot in like
Jordan or anything's fantastic if
everything is real you know this is
taking place in a real city it's not a
Haddonfield it's in Georgetown in
Washington DC and a real University and
sometimes there's actually a real like
priest even Jason Miller is a relative
unknown actor and writer the father died
was a real priest the guy who played
president tom father tom was a real
priest I didn't know that yeah mazing
and it's it's really interesting um
obviously chris mcneil played by a real
actress but we had Linda Blair playing
the girl which is a relative unknown so
it's almost like this Italian Neorealism
thing where it just adds in the more of
the realism not just the setting
absolutely but also Vlad he's a milk
brilliant and well researched writing of
a real case from 1949 of Maryland and
moved to st. Louis but bladdy being from
Maryland and being a Catholic and Jesuit
Georgetown grad knew about this and did
his research for years and took like at
least a year to write that book and then
I finally got produced as a screenplay
and moving that's incredible incredible
stuff yeah freaking definitely has a
sense to him where he's trying to create
something real I read up into the
production he did some interesting stuff
oh yeah reaction oh man there's some
questionable things would you do that
cross your mark would you shoot off a
gun no I would not shoot off a gun by an
actor nor would I slap someone across
the face right before a tape brutal yeah
but you know here's the thing like today
obviously that no one would ever get
yeah whoever was on set would report it
and he might get fired or replaced
instantly but you have to look at the
product of this film yeah and you have
to look at what he was able to create
having harnessed that environment on set
and you have to wonder what you know did
he go too far yes he did but like did he
justified because this film has inspired
you know a few generations now a
filmmakers and will continue to and
there's definitely an environment
created throughout the film that I've
never really seen in another horror
movie before and I've seen all of them
you know I've seen every possession and
exorcism movie saying since this one and
you can still watch this movie and the
reason I think it's so different and
like I said whenever you go back to that
first one that really started the ball
rolling you can see how the progression
throughout the years dumbed it down and
got it more to the base level whereas
this film she takes her to a doctor she
has the the all these experiments to
make sure she's okay you know she has
psychiatrists and it's not like oh she's
she's got the devil it's good exorcism
let's do it right now there's ghosts in
the wall it's like instantaneously you
recognize that there's a sense of
realism here yeah and you have to
tribute that to freaking because he
comes from a documentarian background
just like Michael Mann every time you
know Michael Mann makes the filner of
things so Brown and realism and also the
Scimitar fee holy shit I when I watch
this for the first time everything is
just like like misty like texture to it
and and almost like a fog but there's no
fog there and just like just one light
and the climax and I'm just like oh my
gosh is so Moody and yeah it's just
absolutely brilliant from from start to
finish top to bottom everyone who worked
on that film makeup department dick
Smith doing father Merrin Max von Sydow
was like 30-something I think years old
and he's walking around even he's acting
great job walk around like an old guy
he's his face if you compare like force
awakens Max von Sydow I think there's a
side-by-side photo and the Dick Smith
makeup of the film it's just like the
same it did a wonderful job
Roger Ebert disc
this movie he said that where where a
lot of films simply rest on the screen
The Exorcist is like a frontal assault
very much and I completely agree with
that because you do feel almost like
you're being just thrust into this
horrific experience and like I said I've
seen a mom man and there's nothing
really that gets to this level for me
and that's because of the writing by
bladdy because he took the most extreme
circumstances with these characters and
contrasted them so like you have a
priest who's supposed to be you know
holy
and yet he's having doubts you have this
actress who's actually atheist in her
faith is being tested just like Dimmick
Harris's faith is being tested him it's
you know the daughter is a daughter
really possessed and like this whole
like notion and everything just combats
itself and it's so well-written the
first time the first try we ever have a
demon possession film that everything
else besides that is just a tool yeah
it's kind of funny yeah you look at like
jaws for instance you know and I don't
know what filmmakers were doing in the
70s but right you know in a different
light dude there was a different level
alien alien yeah that's another perfect
example I did a paper a couple months
back for college I had to explore a
chosen genre and I chose horror because
it's fun for me to talk about for her
and I had to basically explore the roots
to modern day so I went back to the 20s
and I talked about nostril raw to and
you know the universal monster movies
the 30s and 40s and when I got to the
70s there was just so much cool shit to
talk about The Exorcist
jaws Halloween and and I started
thinking to myself you know what we're
filmmakers doing then they were just
tapped into something else like they it
was like this whole new generation came
forth and was like hey you know what
we've we've seen some cool shit the 60s
obviously helped a lot with no he's a
peeping tom and psycho and naughty
Living Dead and then the 70s it's almost
like they had permission or something it
was like somebody said hey you're
allowed to do that stuff now and then
freakin came along and made this movie
like you said the first really big
exorcism movie taken seriously with a
budget with a-list actors with a great
writer and
it's as good as it is and no movie about
demons or exorcism has equaled its sense
and and that's just fascinating to me
it's really fat it's like how do you how
do you not have someone not come around
and say like well I can maybe try it but
no they don't it's like there's there's
never been a shark movie better than
Jaws
you're not gonna find a movie about a
alien on a spacecraft and a crew better
than ailing and you're just not going to
I don't think even a film like this or
an alien it would be made today if it
would just be just studio interfered and
or you don't like fine films like truly
great films like this anymore
please Hollywood don't make remake this
oh no don't don't like now this film is
great as standalone like don't remake
Jaws but you know there's only like one
sequel The Exorcist three it's actually
kind of good it's a little bit different
I like that movie I've never seen
Exorcist - you told me to just not even
worry about it
I was like all right but your video you
did on three which is highly recommended
viewing especially if you're a fan of
the film thank you
it's extremely in-depth and it will
without a doubt make you look at the
film differently I really honestly kind
of love three yeah I think it's super
underappreciated yeah it was written and
directed by the guy who wrote the book
and the screenplay oh I'm not thinking
fun fact I think Best Adapted Screenplay
William Peter Blatty for this film the
book is like literally the exact same
this is actually the updated prose it's
the 40th anniversary
but anyways terms the same stuff but he
wrote the screenplay for the film that's
why it's so good too but yeah won Best
Adapted Screenplay because it's
literally the same exact if you just
picked up this book and lose it okay
same movie except like one part where
meirin goes up into the room and says
like online actually Regan says you know
the demon says to Marin but they cut
that and they put it in Exorcist too and
they they ruin it this that's really
yeah I imagine there's more like
in-depth descriptions in the novel oh
yeah a little bit more you know it's
crazy like I'm gonna like a moderate
dyslexic so uh it took me freaking like
from June to like clearly two weeks ago
to read 850 page book of philosophy but
this I finished this in a day like
that's fast as hell yeah this tour
20 pry pages or so you were riveted I
couldn't believe how fast I wrote read
that like wow that's crazy stuff man
yeah Exorcist 3 William Peter Blatty I
wish he made more movies I know yeah I
wish that he had done more because I
think he's uh he was a really really
unique voice underwater a lot of horror
films rely very much on the antagonist
the monster the creature the slasher
villain whoever is you know pounding on
the door but there's something about the
way bladdy would approach things that
felt so much more I don't wanna say I
want to say penetrating like it was just
like got to the root of it hmm something
that got kind of underneath your skin
yeah more so than others yeah I think
you just didn't give a shit because he
was a comedic writer and I think his uh
his latest screenplays for a comedies
cuz he lived in LA he moved to LA and he
wasn't gonna pay for much he said f it
and he just decided to write like this
scary shit and I was a huge risk for him
and it just freaking took off when I got
Leo extremely lucky is he is wrote to my
note here yes please share that with us
okay so um next show that's that's great
yeah so it actually kind of sucks 2015
they had the Exorcist steps
commemoration I missed it I have money
for a plane ticket but uh I think like
right before that I sent this out to him
he signed my copy to my name and with
every good wish Mitt William Peter
Blatty I was like that's the nicest
thing a strangers ever said to me that's
great and then I asked him about writing
advice because I write and you read this
earlier this uh this note pretty much to
just you know work your ass off and then
maybe we get lucky any type of deal so
it's actually really really cool one oh
yeah it's way awesome and actually I
yeah I set them four bucks to send it
back to me
and he gave me my four bucks back that's
he really cool that's great that's he's
got the talent and he's got he's a good
guy rest his soul he died uh a year ago
or thinks I am sucks but yeah great job
but that's great I have a small handful
of things about the film that I think
could have been different
or could have been a little better I
don't love that
Ellen Bernstein's character is an
actress I don't really feel like it adds
much to the film thematically okay I do
wish that there was as you said she was
in Athey
I wish that that was explored a little
more and less focus on like you know the
fact that she's famous like the
detective acts asks for her autograph
and everything and it's it's their nice
little character moments but I just
don't really think it adds much to the
film and maybe maybe there's one or two
too many doctor scenes and that's about
it
gotcha decides that I think it's a great
film I think both of those play into as
a counter or American say to you sure I
would love to it's very subtle but the
films about like a money in a way like
so you notice it's a quick line by
Timmy's uncle Carrie's he says to Damian
like you know if you weren't a priest
that you would be in New York working
and being rich in it as hell because
they're right you know the moms in a
really shitty Hospital and I was like
that's an interesting line and then if
you noticed she Chris MacNeil takes her
daughter to like every hospital every
doctor and they don't know what the
hell's wrong all these tests she's
pissing emboss money and all the science
has no answer for her so doesn't matter
how high you are in status or society
that Manan famous ass actress god or
whatever like this can bring you down
humble you and and really bring it back
down to that's true so you're right I
got even kind of like that Blighty once
again took that contrast of what can I
do to make this the craziest possible
situation let's make her really famous
so that's why yeah I never looked at it
like that you're right the idea of you
know it doesn't really matter how much
money you have how much Fame you have
something primal like this mm-hmm
you can't stop it so yeah you're right
that is an interesting way to look I
never thought of that before yeah isn't
everything that the the six-year-old who
passed by blockbuster and saw the VHS
tapes thought it would be yes but more
so because that six year old who saw
that tape went oh I can't even look at
that oh that's bad yeah yeah it has all
that demon stuff and and the mountain
the the creepiness and the very
frightening imagery and you know she
pukes and she the cross scene which is
oh really messed up brutal but it's
actually more frightening than I had
really expected it to be because um it's
really the deep earthy
was about having a crisis of faith
having doubt finding that faith and then
at that last second making a choice that
redeems you and this family as well as
father Karras huge sacrifice jumps
through the window yeah and also I just
got to say I have never seen a film so
successfully make something as a set of
stairs be so fucking horrified
you're just there's a similar set of
stairs outside this office and I went
into the oven I was like oh God play at
my high school like a couple years ago
my mom's friends kids from middle school
was put on high school but they have a
step so oh my gosh you have to go this
steps let me take a photo before you
leave so I think it's like these long
extras of steps I took a photo and put
it on Twitter like yeah 14 or something
but yeah it's just creepy the way I mean
and you mentioned the editing and
cinematography and that really does come
into play a lot for for things like that
it's just you know Lee Jay Cobb the
detective he's walks up and he just kind
of looks down at the steps and you get
just it's just a wide static of steps
yeah but it's just like the the stuff
that's going on under the surface with
these characters that that really just
makes it so much scarier than it and
then another director if it was in the
wrong hands
yeah this film could have been cheesy it
could be iconic bad yeah but the the
exorcism sequence oh my gosh I think
that's the greatest climax of all time
or the best of their decks ever created
is this oh the mystique
like you said walking by I do this VHS
and it's you know it's yeah I always
says in the poster the scariest move
all-time I think it is I think this is
some scary shit and I don't because it
is so not just based and real in the
movie but based in real life whether you
go Greuther and i think it's real or not
but bloody do the research and uh yeah
it's kind of effed up it's like I own
this I just saw my shelf oh shit you
know there are there are moments in
movies that are very inspiring or that a
very that kind of pumped me up almost
every scene in Rocky you know but
there's a sequence in The Exorcist that
there's no music it's just a reaction
shot and it's father Karras he's
and he's sitting down at the bottom of
the steps and he's done you can tell
he's done like his faith is gone he
knows he's not gonna do anything else
and the crysta mother comes up and says
his my is she gonna die and he just he
looks at her it's like no and he walks
up stir yeah that's no music it's just a
reaction shot and it's just like fuck
yes go back that climb those steps to
the outside Art Museum exactly yeah and
that's um that's great characterization
yeah and that's actually a really great
scene too because they did the whole
first round of the exorcism and Damon
the whole times all like kind of an odd
shock and Marin's they're just like come
on you idiot you just you have lines too
because an exorcism in real life they
supposed to have two priests and there
are two lines to be said so he was just
kind of like BSN or you know not doing
his job
so like yes like you said so he was
defeated and then Maron just said eff it
and he's just you know what himself for
the second session until he's like you
know down-and-out like he said and then
like she's gonna die no no but then I'm
gonna go check on Maron and then he sees
her sees him dead and I'm like oh my
gosh you know what else is really creepy
about that scene she's like she's just
over in the corner of the bed she's just
like yeah just checking it out like
she's just watching like if five of
Karis this is the kind of shit I love
when movies are this good and they make
you think about what was happening when
the scene wasn't playing because then
you realize you're invested so like if
father Karras hadn't run upstairs how
long do you think she would just stared
at his dead body that's a great creepy
that's a great point because I talked
about this max which is three analysis
cuz bladdy wrote the same technique
which is uh arrive late leave early
so like Damien's mom dies and they
actually like say it I think Dyer says
it yeah like there's so many moments
like like Sharon like brings carriers
like oh my gosh come like spent like oh
what's happening oh yeah so it's more
tension to your body yeah anxiety goes
through the roof more so that that's a
problem I have with a lot of movies
nowadays is um you can almost say in
your head like the scenes about to end
true you know like oh that's how the
scene ends he's the director is his end
the scene right now but it doesn't feel
like that and that kind of plays into
that sense of unnerving that that I feel
throughout the film like the jogging
scene and they're just talking and Lee
Jacobs like his head was down completely
around I'm like oh shit you know and and
their scenes like that that build it
like you said and they get to that point
of where it's at a high and they don't
give you the release they don't give you
that jump scare that makes you go okay
yes okay now I can breathe there's very
few very yeah and even even those
moments they end right at the right spot
like the spider walk scene well yeah
those walking down the steps yeah and
they're just custom black yeah you know
you know you don't even get like a much
of a reaction from them you're kind of
left feeling what they might feel and
right and I think the next scene after
that straight Damien and interrogating
her or something I think that yeah
you're totally right the movie never
gives you those those breathe moments
there's very few and you can almost
count them off you come on one hand I
really can't most of them come from Lee
Jacob yeah comedy moments like he'll be
like it's it's not actually for my
daughter it's for me or you know asking
about seeing a film you know and there's
those little tiny moments where you can
laugh but for the most part the movies
like Roger Ebert said it's a frontal
assault on your nerves what's crazy is
about that scene was like yeah I can't
do it for my daughter that scene is so
long but it grounds yourself for realism
because you know this time is happening
real for this scene is happening real
time and the right for that is some
effed up shit that happens but it's all
like one sequence like say for example
uh the director's cut includes the
spider walk or the spider crawl there's
a oh the whole thing of Burke gangs like
oh my gosh that's kind of effed up but
then like another thing like bladdy like
wrote something crazy and then said I'm
gonna do something even crazier than
your own standard tropes and I'm gonna
do another crazy thing in the same scene
that's just like as a viewer especially
watching it for the first time you're
like what you're not expecting like that
to happen
we're so expecting this exactly we're so
used to the way scenes play we're so
used to like this is where a cut happens
yes you know like this is where the next
scene happens the rules say that this
scene should be about this length and
then here we get into the second actor
here we have the inciting incident and
then later we'll have the first five
minutes later this pop point exactly and
and while the film in some ways plays
into a formula that you can watch and
feel like you're invested in a story a
narrative you're right it breaks those
rules and I love films like that I love
when a movie is going and it's going and
it's going and it's still going and the
scenes still going Spielberg does that
amazing when he 20 builds and crafts
sequences because you talk a lot you
know in film school you know people talk
about scenes and moments and character
beats and arcs and where to do that you
just don't see as many filmmakers
anymore crafting these epic sequences
that feel like they're they're just this
overarching thing that's occurring and
The Exorcism sequence is one of those
it's a lot of scenes but it's all
harnessed in one and I mentioned this
all the time the t-rex break out in your
first Jurassic Park that's not a scene
it as soon as the power goes out as soon
as they stop in front the t-rex paddock
it feels like every single moment after
that is building to the t-rex stomping
off into the forest what a touch exactly
yeah and and that's a that's a
collection of scenes and and that's
something friken did so well with this
movie understanding how to build that
it's interesting you said that because I
was watching again I noticed how much he
moved the camera I think it's a trait of
Spielberg how much he moves the camera
it's very suburban yeah yeah I remember
being blown away by the directing the
first time but second time I really
noticed like wow he really did move it
like that and I don't know if you've
seen anything behind the scenes stuff
like then it has steadicams and shit so
what they had no shit they had a
freaking chair and a pulley system and
they would just like pull the person on
the chair with their feet up and like
that one tracking shot where she's like
going crazy I'm Abed for the first time
and they go from the frickin like front
door and they go up the steps and like
so it's somebody on like a chair and I'm
like with the freaking camera and then
they follow them like all the way up and
yeah yes it was pretty crazy it's that's
respect there's another crazy like snore
cam type shot where Regan grabs the
doctor's nuts but then like the cam
like oh the guys like here nearly falls
back so like the rig they made was like
a chair and they had a guy in a chair
and like his all woods their blocks
whatever and then they kind of like
tilting them back it's incredible so
much that's not a great thing about this
film all practical effects when she's
levitating that's wires mm-hmm all the
shit was non CG and all that stuff the
breath you know a story about the breath
how they achieved that negative 25
degree room okay nobody Hartman who did
for the thing no digital breath and you
got to give it to Linda Blair in this
role because she had no point of
reference she couldn't look at other
films and say like what's what is a
possessed girl act like you know I mean
the voices which another actress
provided at times and there were
different sounds and everything
speaking of sounds have you heard about
the pigs it was for just the are is it
yeah supposedly when the demon leaves
yes his goes into father Karras it was a
sound of pigs
yeah do you understand the biblical
significance yes I think also the pigs
were like getting led into slaughter
yeah yeah the biblical significance you
can test me if I'm wrong but yeah
there's a demon in a lady I think of
Jesus cast out the demon into the pigs
and the pigs went over the cliff you're
absolutely right yeah yeah I looked that
up and I'm always fascinated when a
director is able to put little things
like that in the film you know and
that's just like if this film wasn't as
famous as it is I doubt that anyone will
have ever picked up on that those little
details but when you start analyzing it
and really looking into it that just
shows you that they were really
legitimately trying to make a good movie
like they went above and beyond great
Java filmmakers a great job by a Warner
for not censoring it is there yeah they
could have easily Center the shit that
is movie like that yeah they fix blood
it was very controversial we have movies
like The Exorcist to thank for so many
other 'mo you sit down you watch the
conjuring probably wouldn't exist
without this no I don't think any of
them would honestly know I'm gonna give
the Exorcist an A
so I give a great if you want to I'll go
to billion out of ten I'll try to I'll
put that number well man thank you so
much for joining me on this video thanks
for every I knew for a fact if I was
ever gonna review this movie and had to
be you I mean you've got the knowledge
you have a sign letter from William
Peter Blatty I mean there's nobody else
that would ever join me on an exercise
every Joe's got autograph so guys please
do check out mass channel the link is in
the description below as always if you
liked this you can click right here and
get stuck mint iced
you